Chris Collins coach Collins who joins us
now the northwestern head coach hi coach
how are you good morning it's been a
long time good to be talking to you okay
a week ago this would have been a great
interview now you lose to Purdue so
let's try to salvage it and make it a
good interview can you do that I'll
pressure i'm always in a good mood i'm
always in a good mood so i'll deliver
for you what what what is the general
consensus did the win against michigan
put you in the tournament i'm not sure i
mean you always want to try to control
what you can control by continuing to
win you know I if you ask me of course
just like most coaches we know teams I
feel like we're good enough I feel you
know we've we've done a lot we have five
true road wins in the Big Ten which
isn't easy we had a good non-conference
slate and picked up some good wins there
and you know 10 wins in the Big Ten so
you know I thought I thought would I
thought we needed to win more games than
we lost in the big ten to be in the mix
and the Michigan when gave us that tent
conference win and it's kind of crazy
the way it happened with the long pass
and finish and so you know I'm hopeful
but uh the best thing we can do is go to
the conference tournament key pointed
the expectations when you got to
northwestern were what well you know the
expectations I put on myself for high I
was excited by the challenge and the
opportunity it's kind of the way I'm
wired you know a lot of people you know
discouraged me from coming coming to a
place like this I was at Duke I was at
my school I was working with Coach K a
lot of winning coach and a lot of great
players had a great life and you know to
go somewhere that was kind of you know
had no tradition didn't have the winning
culture great school great city my
hometown but really no basketball
history to speak of you know that was an
exciting challenge for me I wanted to
come in I knew it would probably take a
little time didn't know how long it was
going to be but I felt I believed I
believed right away I believe this was a
place that could become good that could
become a program that could be relevant
urine and year out I just thought go
we had a lot of things going for us with
where we were right outside of Chicago
in the Big Ten really good academic
school I just thought it was a great
opportunity and I had to go out and get
the guys and the players that were wired
like I was that would I would want the
same challenge how long were you with
Coach K 17 years total for as a player
and 13 as an assistant so quite quite a
few years with that guy I soaked up as
much as I could but was this the first
head coaching opportunity you him why
dad said I had had some discussions with
some schools you know nothing for me
just felt right I mean I'm a big I'm a
big gut feel guy you know and you know
go with your heart and what you feel and
I just never really felt it with any of
the other situations when I talk to
places and this one was just a little
different you knows the timing was right
you know I felt I'd been at Duke for 13
years I had the opportunity to coach k
for two Olympic cycles and be a part of
two Olympic gold medal winning teams and
I just felt this situation and I grew up
right by this campus went to high school
here I love Chicago you know I loved
everything to school represented it
reminded me a lot from the people
perspective of what Duke was and again I
was excited by the challenge of doing a
lot of verse and so was it just all kind
of came together and was the right time
right place and it's been a great bit i
love it and i really have loved watching
this program grow over the last four
years do you tell coach k you're leaving
or do you ask him about leaving at first
you ask and uh you know it was funny he
was probably the biggest champion you
know for this situation for me I mean no
one knows that no one knows me like he
does you know he's been around me he
coached me he knows my personality knows
my strengths and weaknesses and when
northwestern contacted me and I went to
him for advice he told me I had to do it
you know he was the one he said this is
perfect for you it's everything you're
looking for it's a place where you can
make a mark you can leave a legacy he
said you got to go do this which which
made me feel good because that's kind of
what I was feeling as well
put this delicately as only I can you
you were known as a shooter don't pull
any punches okay I'm a beer come on now
to somebody who didn't play defense how
do you how do you teach defense for
somebody who didn't play defense that's
a good question i get that often uh I
never got into Stan's much when I played
my my my van point of defense was
outscoring my man you know I felt if I
outscored my man and I played good
defense but uh you know it's something
that we've had to hang our hat on as we
built our program because quite frankly
we just for you know we hadn't had the
firepower especially in our conference
to match up with the likes of the
Wisconsin's and Indiana's and Michigan
State's and so on and so forth keep
going down the line would so we had to
become a hard-nosed defensive team to to
be able to be competitive I think it's
become part of our identity which like
you said the people who know me best
can't believe that we're likely to find
a team but I'm gonna keep on him while I
can he's Chris Collins the northwestern
head coach owning a Stan Patrick show
the best shooter on the team right now
you included is who me yeah it's like an
advocate the cultures were included oh
absolutely should I take myself look dan
I have a thing in my family and my kids
and wife get really mad how we tell them
when we compete at home whoever gets
second place in the board game or the
competition or the video game actually
wins because I always wanted so it's uh
so no it's I always mess with the guys I
have no I never had great foot speed so
I can't really play anymore anyway but i
can still outshoot them but uh hopefully
they'll be hopefully there'll be a day
where some guys on the team can outshoot
me that that would mean that we're a
pretty good team my wife brought this up
to me over the weekend about being
competitive I told her I'm trying not to
be as competitive and she said the
person who talked trying to show your
kids doing shoots and ladders in
Candyland that's true they were like
five and I'm in their face mocking them
doing Candyland so it's tough to let go
okay also Julia Louie Dreyfus his son is
a walk-on on the team the first dating
you had with her
or how did that go you know obviously I
was a for me I was a big fan of Seinfeld
and if loved watching earn so they come
in and sit down and they couldn't be
better Charlie ya'lls parents they
couldn't be better people brought on an
old Saturday Night Live really good
writer producer actor himself and then
Julie I mean they're just normal parents
they came in very understated they're so
proud of their son there was no
awkwardness they all look they are quite
funny though maybe you know that
probably doesn't surprise you but
they're very entertaining and funny and
they're just great people it's been
awesome to have Charlie in our program
and there are a lot of the games and
they're just in the parent section and
they're just regular parents which I
love I mean you got the probably the
most famous comedic actress of all time
and everything she's accomplished but
yet when she's around here she just saw
his mom and and I respect that so much
they're awesome people but do you feel
like you have to give him a little extra
playing time if you see Julia Louie
Dreyfus in there Chris uh quite there
yet but uh it's uh I tell you what
though he sees great dad on the team and
he's really added you know sometimes
even though he doesn't play as much out
there just his personality he keeps
everybody you know he's the comedian
he's the high-energy guy that keeps
everybody loose and he's been a great
addition for our program Steve would you
help you just slap the floor listening
to this interview just let you know did
you ever smoke I lay off oh my god Chris
did you ask my guy I do you think I
could take loge in a shooting contest no
way no way Rojo's underrated offensively
I'll tell you that he he's overrated
invincibly he'll get after you now I'm
the wrong turn on the wrong person to
attack words i'm gonna i'm going with
row Joe to the desk so
I'll defend that guy to the day I die
he's a brother to me and I know we're
just teasing but I'm so proud of him you
know what he's the one at Marquette and
we spent a lot of years together we were
teammates and then coached together for
13 years and you know we've been in a
lot of foxholes and there's nobody trust
me there's nobody that I'd rather be in
in a competition in a battle and a big
game within that guy he's a great
teammate and a heck of a fighter got a
little serious there on me Chris all
right i did because that's my guy yeah
all right if I took all the former
dukey's right now and we're going to
have a shooting contest yes I can't put
ready to retic in there wait you can't
predict in there do you want to put
Redick in there I mean if you do it's a
pretty much a no-brainer okay can I put
myself yes I realize helping yeah you're
in but do you want you want to pisa
retic I mean I don't you know Redick is
kind of you know what I have with Redick
Redick is redic and I are like brothers
you know I was fortunate to help recruit
him and you know I was in his wedding
and we're very close and I have that big
brother thing on Redick so even though
he's like to talk a little brother no
matter how good the little brother gets
you just can't be big brother so I mean
I let it became the player that I always
wanted to be I mean coaches say that all
the time you know when I would watch him
play as a junior and senior he was the
guy I wanted to be I just wasn't quite
good enough to do that the way he played
all those things but in competition if I
had I still have that big brother
syndrome on him so I still like my
chances against reading and a shooting
my lightest and to answer your question
do you do you teach the fake charge that
that now there's a class at Duke to
teach us a car key on the tickets in
there a charge taking class there a
deuca like fake like dramatic is there
an actor who teaches that you do that at
Northwest I thought if I told you all
those deep dark secrets I'd have to kill
your dad so I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to keep that in the wall you never
you never took a charge though I mean
why get dirty I mean no there's no
reason for that for you no I just wanted
to score absolutely thankfully and and
and and you've done a great job I mean
it's really been an incredible story and
you need the perspective of
understanding northwestern and where
they were to where they are now so
congrats that's uh that's a big jump but
you know people are never ever ever
going to forget that moment when you
beat Michigan and how you beat Michigan
and of course you designed to play must
have been practiced many many many times
in practice right absolutely absolutely
not actually it was crazy that was a
that was a spur-of-the-moment put
together play my assistant coach
actually cut is in charge of all our
special situations long passes late game
plays and he drew it up and that worked
to prepare lessee those plays well maybe
one out of 20 or whatever but it worked
that night and was just a magical night
that do it at home and you know I think
what everything that the game the
implications that that game had one of
those it's one of those memories in our
program I hope it's just the beginning
no I mean that's to me we're just
starting where we ultimately want to go
so was uh was an amazing night really
fun time and just excited to go into
postseason what a time of the year hey
Chris Congrats been great and your poor
dad watching you play mentor oh I feel I
feel bad like making pork it's it's it's
torture oh my I've been happy the last
couple games he's been he's been
assigned to work while we've been
playing so it's been good for the mental
health he could just look at the score
afterwards and not have to deal with the
two hours of torture congrats good luck
in the tournament Chris alright thanks
Ann you're the best night that's Chris
Collins you can still shoot better than
you can just ask him I love that
continental Coaches Corner brought to
you by continental tire wheel of these
folks and you're going to love the tires
go to canoodle tired calm continental
tire for what you do no matter what it
is any questions if you want to get the
best tires if you're rotating tires they
have advice for you on all of these
items its continental tire calm
continental tire for what you do the Dan
Patrick show
weekday morning on audience